here is a simulation created by Khan
Academy user Justin helps that once
again tries to give us an understanding
of why we divide by n minus 1 to get an
unbiased estimate of population variance
when we're trying to calculate the
sample variance so what he does here is
a simulation it has a population that
has a uniform distribution so he says I
used a flat probabilistic distribution
from 0 to 100 for my population then we
start sampling from that population
we're going to use samples of size 50
and what we do is for each of those
samples we calculate the variance based
on dividing by n we calculate the sample
variance based on dividing by n by
dividing by n minus 1 and n minus 2 and
as we keep having more and more and more
samples we take the mean of the
variances calculated in different ways
and we figure out what those means
converge to so that's a sample here's
another sample here's another sample if
I sample here then I'm now adding a
bunch and I'm sampling continuously and
you saw something very interesting
happen when I divide by n I get my my my
sample variance is still even when I'm
taking the mean of many many many many
sample variances that I've already taken
I'm still under estimating the true
variance when I divide by n minus 1 it
looks like I'm getting a pretty good
estimate the mean of all of my sample
variances is really converged to the
true variance when I divided by n minus
2 just for kicks it's pretty clear that
I overestimated that I overestimated the
with my mean of my sample variances i
overestimated the true variance so this
gives us a pretty good sense that n
minus 1 is the right thing to do now
this is another way another interesting
way of visualizing it in the horizontal
axis right over here we're comparing
each plot is one of our samples and how
far to the right is how much more is
that sample mean than the true mean and
when we go to the left it's how much
less is the sample mean than the true
mean so for example this sample right
over here it's all the way over to the
right it's the sample mean there was a
lot more than the true mean sample mean
here was a lot less than the true mean
sample mean here only a little bit more
than the true mean in the vertical axis
using this denominator dividing by n we
calculate two different variances
one variance we use the sample mean the
other variance we use the population
mean and this in the vertical axis we
compare the difference between the mean
calculated with the sample mean versus
the mean calculated with the population
mean so for example this point right
over here when we calculate our mean
with our sample mean which is a normal
way we do it it significantly
underestimates what the mean would have
been if somehow we knew what the
population mean was and we could
calculate it that way and you get this
really interesting shape and it's
something to think about it you
recommend some thinking about why or
what kind of a shape this actually is
the other interesting thing is when you
look at it this way it's pretty clear
this entire graph is sitting below the
horizontal axis so we're always when we
calculate our sample variance using this
formula what when we use the sample mean
to do it which we typically do we're
always under s we're always getting a
lower variance then when we then when we
use the population mean now this over
this over here when we divide by n minus
one we're not always under estimating
sometimes we're overestimating it and
when you take the mean of all of these
variances you converge and here we're
overestimating it a little bit more and
just to be clear what we're talking
about in these three graphs let me take
a screenshot of it and explain it a
little bit more depth so just to be
clear just to be clear in this red graph
right over here let me do this color
close to at least so this orange what
this distance is for each of these
samples we're calculating we're
calculating the sample variance using so
let me using the sample mean and in this
case we are using n as our denominator
in this case right over here and from
that we're subtracting the sample
variance or I guess you could call this
some kind of pseudo sample variance if
we somehow knew if we somehow knew the
population mean this isn't something
that you see a lot in statistics but
it's a gauge of how much we are under
estimating our sample our sample
variance given that we don't have the
true population mean at our disposal and
so this is the distance
this is the distance we're calculating
you see we're always we are always under
estimating here we overestimate a little
bit and we also underestimate but when
you take the mean when you average them
all out it converges to the actual value
so here we're dividing by n minus 1 here
we're dividing by n minus 2